Hey,
how you doing? Hey. Hey. We got I got my
buddy who said something about my
destiny. What's my destiny?
>> Okay. Your destiny is to face the truth.
The lie of Christianity. The
>> lie of Christianity. The lie of
Christianity. Why' you have to start
with that, man?
>> Wait a minute. Christianity invented by
you guys. Not that which was brought by
you.
>> Hey, check this out. Check this out.
Now, everyone, everyone check this out.
We got some awesome times right here.
Hey, you guys will be able to hear us
cuz we got this mic. So,
>> hey David,
we got
we got everyone. Everyone check this
out. Check this out. This is awesome.
This is awesome.
>> We got We got We got Muhammad. Everyone,
right? Everyone heard Muhammad.
Muhammad. His first impression of his
revelations was that they were demonic.
>> He tried to hurl himself off a cliff. He
became suicidal. That's the impression
that his revelations had on him. It was
his wife and her cousin who convinced
them that he's actually a prophet.
>> He admittedly delivered revelations from
Satan. They're called the Satanic
Verses.
>> Called the Satanic Verses.
>> He was a victim. He was a victim of
black magic that gave him
false beliefs.
>> Jesus got his butt here. We respect
Jesus. We respect Jesus. Take care. We
respect Jesus. Look how they You got
Jesus and you've got Muhammad, the man
who had sex with a prophecy as a
nyear-old girl who took the wife
who took the wife of his own adopted
son. His revelation said he could have
wives he took nine.
He's got all these prophets now in all
the verses and the only thing
to show that he's a prophet is that our
scriptures confirmed him
the scriptures confirm him and then he
died
in exact
but we've got who's going to give us the
reason why we should believe in what he
said about the prophet Muhammad in that
he gave all the details of what happened
in Najan but they weren't there without
a shadow of doubt because that
information about is nowhere to be found
in Islamic
details like that.
>> No answer at all.
>> No answer. No answer. We have to add to
the Bible and try to claim that the
Jesus was killed was defeated by the
devil. But he's lying about what Matthew
actually says. It never says the devil
beat Jesus in Matthew 4. Jesus beat him
after fasting for 40 days and then after
after several in physical torment then
the angels came and ministered
>> after a physical torment this is God
being tormented by the de let's go to
the book of salvation listen let's end
this you said that after physical
torment yes or no
>> no I said physical starvation
>> oh busy running already running already
torment now you salvation. Now, let me
say you're talking about Jesus willingly
fasting every day. The devil did not
harm him or claim it's not in Matthew
and I asked you to show me a verse. I
told you there. No, read it. Read it.
Read it. Read it. Read it. Read it. Read
it.
>> I don't have it in front of me.
>> Oh, you don't have it in front of me.
Read it. Read it. Read it. Read it. Read
it. Read it. Read it. You think this
establishes your truth? I think this is
really cool. No, you think it
establishes your truth, not allowing you
to listen to me.
>> Then the devil left him and behold
angels came and were ministering to him.
Why does it say two angels minister to
God? Why? And how?
>> Because again, he was fasting for 40
days.
>> So God was fasting week on bread alone.
>> So they missed the whole part about the
the incarnation. He missed that. Now
he's missed that part. Now he's missed
that part. your life.
How is the the angels administered to
God?
>> Where does God in the Old Testament say
that his angels are responsible for his
welfare and wellbeing? Give me the
verse. And where does he say he'll take
that form?
>> Say the devil.
This dude right here say the devil
tormented him.
>> This dude right here
tormented him. I've been watching you.
Your sanity is doubtful. So let me talk.
Okay. So that's so
I'm here in front of you nowbody.
>> You don't want tobody
can I talk to everybody
one second my brother.
>> So guys we need the space so that our
debaters can debate with room and you
guys can see things and the camera can
catch everything. Okay.
>> So, you guys are good. Can you guys all
hear me?
>> Let me hear you say Jesus is God if you
can hear me.
>> Cool. All right. That's good. Now, so
>> so we're all good here.
>> Well, well, radar apologetics in the
building. Yo,
[Applause]
>> so this is the IRL. My energy is the
live stream. Here's this mic. What's up,
live stream?
I hear about not against you.
>> Yeah, we're good. Okay. So now
you
secretary. Okay. So now
>> all right. So did you hear the verse?
>> Me and your knowledge.
>> What we're going to do is please listen.
What we're going to do now,
>> we have we have top people.
>> What we're going to do now is talk about
what is most important.
>> Yeah. The Islamic dilemma.
>> Yep.
>> We're going to talk about whether
Muhammad is a true prophet. And Sadik is
going to prove it for us because he's
been doing this for years. So if anyone
can show us that Muhammad is a true
prophet and not a child molesting,
murdering rapist of a false prophet, he
can do it.
>> Listen how you see. Listen.
>> I want you to look around you.
>> I'm the only Muslim here.
>> That's right. Hey, give it up for him.
You're the only Muslim.
>> I'm just rice and bean eating with
something that keeps it real. That's
right. You heard?
>> Okay. So, I'm here in defense and doing
the best I can in odds that won't allow
me in reality to express myself. So,
therefore, let's do this. The crux of
the matter is this and one only.
Christianity is based.
>> Hey, he said Christianity is based.
>> Hey, make sure you clip that. Can't say
anything else.
>> Thank you.
>> Live convert live new top DA leader gets
converts to Christianity.
>> You see this is what I mean. What is
this intended to do? This is intended to
divert to divert what the points that
I'm going to bring up and what I want to
talk about because that is why
Christianity focuses completely and
totally on problemics against Islam to
keep the pressure off the Bible to keep
pressure off Christianity because
Christianity cannot be defended. Notice
this though just I want to respond to
that because he he said that like
Christianity focuses on pimics meaning
arguments against Islam. But last time I
checked does the Bible mention Islam at
all y'all?
Do do you know that the the Quran talks
about us more than it talks about
Muhammad?
>> That's crazy, isn't it? So, it looks
like Islam is actually a pyic against
us, man. We ain't even thinking about
y'all.
>> Yeah, you talked about us first. Your
God and your prophet talked about us way
before we ever heard of your God and
your prophet.
>> Don't whine. Don't whine when we
respond. Your book calls us the worst of
creatures. Do we get to respond? Your
book says that our religion is false. Do
we get to respond? They want this world
where they get to blast us, call for
violence against us, even kill us, and
we just have to sit here like good
demies and take it all. Too bad, we are
not, have never been, and never will be
your demies.
First of all, if you want to talk about
demies, the action of demies actually
occurred in the Bible who begins in the
Bible is what you call tributaries in
the Bible where in fact in the book of
Deuteronomy, it talks about tributary
one
of Deuteronomy where you are to fight
people that are far off, not a threat
from you, not a threat, and subject
them. If they do not subject and allow
themselves to be tributaries, siphoning
everything that they have to you, then
they are to be put to the sword Samarian
killed. This is called tributaries. One
second. And if Sadique thinks that's a
problem,
I'll be quick. I'll be quick. If Sadi
thinks that the book of Deuteronomy is
immoral and wicked, why did his God and
his prophet affirm it as the inspired
preserved authoritative word of God that
we are supposed to judge by? You just
condemned your own fake prophet.
Sadique.
I condemned my fake prophet.
>> Yeah, you did. did it with your mouth
when you won't allow me to speak and
defend it. Now, that's a whole
>> I'm just pointing out. I'm assuming you
want to be a good Muslim. If you want to
be a good Muslim, you shouldn't be
attacking your God and your prophet.
>> Okay, listen to me.
>> I'll do that for you.
>> Can I do that? Listen, you got squashed
by Daniel Hak.
>> Oh, no.
Can I finish? Did I Daniel?
>> You got Can I finish a point? The second
you said that the Bible does not confirm
the Bible, you killed the entire of your
of the Islamic. What? Now let me go now.
Please let me can I please.
>> All right. Let me just
look.
>> I'm going to go let me make a I thought
you just did.
>> No, let me just let me just let me just
unite us in one subject. Now
>> now the subject I want to unite us in
Jesus is Lord.
ignore. Ignore him. He's He's just a
troll.
>> Yeah. You see, you see what you have to
know about David Wood is that his life,
his freedom depends on Islam. Because
you see, if it wasn't for Let me finish.
If it wasn't, let me finish. If it
wasn't for Islam, David Wood would
succumb to his psychosis. Wow. Now, let
me finish.
>> Hey. Hey, that's true.
>> Can everyone imagine what would have
happened if I had converted to Islam in
prison? There would be massive piles of
dead bodies all over the place.
>> Baby ducks, chickens, and and kittens.
Chickens and kittens. You'd have been
killing them. Now, let's talk about
that. Now, let's please.
>> He's right. But it's not because of
Islam. It's thanks to the Lord Jesus
Christ.
>> See, that's called playing to the crowd,
which is 99.
>> You play to the Muslims praying play to
the crowd. No, they would never do that.
>> No, but you did, man. You got a tight.
>> Now, listen.
>> The most important thing. Yeah.
>> The most important thing to
Christianity, call it however you want
to call it, Christianity is this offer
of salvation. Is am I right or wrong?
Did Christianity rest its existence on
the death and resurrection of Jesus? Yes
or no?
>> Yes,
>> that's true.
>> Okay. Now, I have a question.
>> The Apostle Paul in the book of In the
Apostle Paul, by the way, take a look at
that. You see light?
>> Look at my face.
>> This is called Noah. You're a white boy.
I'm Puerto Rican
the light. That's called north. But
anyway, so you know who else was really
white?
>> Muhammad.
>> Yes. And Muhammad had a son who remain
married into his family and became the
general of his armies and his
descendants became the general of his
armies. Don't ever talk. Wait a minute.
Do not ever talk. What's his son?
>> His adopted said not do that.
>> His adopted son. Whoa. The son he took
his wife from.
Let me tell you something.
>> He's talking about his son. It's not his
son. Allah abolished adoption so that he
could bang his adopted son's wife.
>> Very nice. Very nice. But you see that's
his take because you see
>> surah 33
4:5 abolishes adoption in Islam. And it
was to justify Muhammad banging the wife
of his own adopted son. This sick
pervert. First of all,
>> a sick pervert. The sick pervert was
Isaac. But anyway, let me go.
We We respect the prophets. We respect
all prophets. Everyone
prophets, can I can I finish?
>> Sure.
>> Show us continue.
>> The Bible and let me please I want you
all to listen to this.
>> The reason that the David The reason
that the Bible puts the prophets in
positions where they are not completely
perfect, where they show their human
side, do you know why?
so that God could show that his
forgiveness and mercy was before Jesus
and after him. That he forgave prophets
that did what they did and that his
mercy extended to them. And in fact,
those descendants of prophets,
descendants of prophets that committed
certain acts where they had children are
in the very genealogies of Jesus Christ
in the book of Matthew, book of Luke.
Now, let me continue. Let me say some
please, David. Let me say this.
Salvation is extremely important. Right.
Right.
>> This is what you stand on. you what you
offer for the benefit of mankind is the
offer of salvation and forgiveness and
mercy from God through Jesus.
>> Right.
>> Right. So I'm asking you let's put that
to the test. Did the Apostle Paul in the
book of Hebrews chapter 10:18 who said
uh that the blood of Jesus will end
blood sin sacrifice forever? Is that
statement completely scripturally true?
Let me preface it by saying this. The
Apostle Paul claimed to be a
>> That's not what we're talking about. But
this is what we're going to talk about
also.
Get out of here.
>> Not your demies, buddy. Not your demies,
please.
>> Yeah, that's not what we're talking
about.
>> If you do, if you you see this whole
thing rest,
>> I have no problem talking about that
next.
>> All right, let's talk about this and
then I'll talk about that.
>> Okay. All right. Take care of yourself.
Watch your head on the way out.
>> Cook them. Watch your head on the way
out.
>> So, so we have here you you came to my
event and we got topics. We've been
running this topic the same way with
every Muslim. We just went to a Muslim
booth today, y'all. And they couldn't
give us a single answer on why is it
that the Quran confirms the Bible yet
contradicts it. So, you're here. You're
very confident. You seem very
knowledgeable. You got your notes. So,
let's deal with the topic at hand first
and then we can go wherever you want.
You got look, you got my word. If you
want to talk about your subject, you
have no we have no problem. deal with
the Islamic dilemma first and then we
could talk about sin sacrifices.
>> You can talk about You can talk about
dilemma. Wait a minute. You can talk
about
>> then I will take you over there. We'll
do a live on my Tik Tok and we can go
through. You can talk about dilemma all
you want. It's your dilemma. Wait a
minute. But if you don't have foundation
where you're legitimate where you're
legitimate, then you got to shut your
mouth.
>> Hallelujah. Wait
a minute.
>> So since our Muslim friends have no
foundation for what they believe and the
foundations rip themselves apart as they
affirm our scripture contradicts its
Islam has no foundation and not
according to me. I'm happy to let people
say but Sadik says that Muslims need to
shut their mouths.
>> It's not in the Old Testament the dual
nature. In fact, when Jesus came and
spent 40 days, let me ask you, did he
teach the the disciples the ins and outs
and the mechanics of dual nature? Yes or
no?
>> Did the Quran? He's attacking the Bible
that his God and his prophet and he
doesn't get it.
>> We can't answer a question. Yeah, we
can. Did the Quran affirm that?
>> Did the Does the Quran affirm what?
>> The gospel that Jesus whatever he taught
in the gospel that we read in Matthew,
what he's going over with his disciples,
does the Quran confirm that?
>> No. So then what does it confirm? Now
let me tell you now when you allow me
what does it compare
in jail in jail in jail
in jail in jail in jail.
Now listen
but anyway
let me give you and I'm going to be
brief on this. Quran from the very
beginning establishes because we in
Islam are completely entire. This is why
we stick to certain hadith and certain
sayings like for instance that in a
hadith that says that God has we want to
say two right arms, two left hands and
two we stick to it. We stick to it
because if it is written by God and it's
there in scripture then the Muslim says
we take it for what it says and we don't
interpret it. We leave it at that. We
leave it at that. I love it. Then your
book says affirm it affirms our book,
our gospel, our our Torah and it orders
us. And if you don't interpret it, then
go with what it says. That's the Islamic
dilemma. How are you not getting this?
Can I finish?
>> So then the Quran, you see, this is what
he must do. And this is what you are all
about here now. Not to allow an answer
to flow. And
>> we've been waiting. We're waiting. But
how is it when every single time I try
to make a
>> Okay. All right. Let me let me shut him
down. Hey, David. Now let me
>> shut out.
>> Okay, brother. Now let me ask now let me
ask you on Islamic dilemma. This is what
you want.
>> Okay. Yeah. This is what I want.
>> Okay. Now so the Quran then affirms
because this is the righteousness of
Allah and the truth of Allah that he is
the one who inspired scripture and
revelation to mankind. That's part of
his mercy. And he affirms therefore that
he inspired and generated the Bible, the
Torah and the Eg or what you would call
the New Testament that this that he
inspired it and he does not deny it. the
Quran. In fact, the Quran mentions more
talks about other prophets more than it
does the prophet Muhammad and more about
other things because it's not a book
dedicated to selling,
>> you know, itself like the Bible is
dedicated to selling Judaism.
It is a book a guidance for all of
mankind free of that type of of that
type of aspect. Okay? Now, so when the
Quran affirms this and it says that,
okay, let me finish that the Bible was
indeed revealed and inspired by God
without shadow of a doubt.
>> But then what happens is but then what
happens is what is held in esteem is the
law. The halak the
>> how you say it
>> the
law because that is eternal in Islam.
Mr. Sharia. Now the law is extremely
important because that is the means by
which society culture is defined and by
the way it moves together and evolves.
So law is extremely important. So the
Quran then verifies the law that was
given. Now look what the Quran can let
me finish this part.
>> You said you come on bro.
>> Let me just finish this point.
>> All right. I'll let you wrap this up man
cuz the point right here is then after
that the Quran then takes on the
obligation as it says in the Quran. This
is a scripture that has come to protect
its truth that which came before it. So
then the the Quran takes a line item
approach to the theological claims of
the Bible. This is why I did it. Let me
ask you where does the Quran confirm
that Jesus Christ is the son of God who
has a Greek equality to God who is
eternally generated with God who has
wait a minute. who who has God's essence
and nature that where does God affirm
that son and that he is going to die for
our sins on the third day
>> easy can we answer that yeah sure 2:41
it says believe in what we have revealed
>> confirming what is with you so what is
with them now guys did you guys hear his
question his question was where does the
Quran confirm this this concept of a a
son of god who is equal in nature with
the father and so on and so forth So
when it says that the Quran confirms
that which is with them in possession of
the Jews and Christians, what was with
them? IP
>> the gospel.
>> The gospel. And in the gospel, it says,
"For God so loved the world that he gave
his only son that whoever believes in
him should not perish but have
everlasting life." It also says in the
go, look, you went up for a very long
time. It also says in the gospel in John
chapter 6:40 that whoever this is the
will of my father that all who look on
the son and believes in him will have
eternal life and I will raise him up on
the last day. Here's another one. In the
gospel it says that before times the god
has revealed himself and spoken by many
prophets. I need Hey, I need you to pay
attention. Pay attention.
>> Okay. Okay. Good. I'm glad. Just get
just give me a second.
>> Did I let him Did I let him turn? And
then I let him talk. Did I interrupt
him? I I even I even I even put David on
the leash for you.
>> I even put David on the leash for you.
But I let him talk for three minutes
straight. We waited for an answer and we
didn't get an answer. So So here it is.
So I gave you I gave you what the gospel
says about the divine son. And so now
your Quran confirms what was with them
of the gospel. So that's where your
Quran confirms that. Okay. No. Number
one.
Unfortunately, the uh the kind gentleman
over there, the police told us that we
need to move right here by the barricade
because we're obstructing on both sides.
>> He remembers us from November and he
said we grown a lot. So, he said it's
great for the ministry, but now we're
obstruction. So, we need to go over
there. The barricade. I I hate to say
this, but too many people support us.
It's a good thing. God is good. Glory to
God. But we got to move for the black
Americans over there.